其他人：OK
Others: OK
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Jake:买了
Jake: Bought it.
其他人：已经有了
Others: Already got it.
Jake:什么叫有了
Jake: What do you mean got it?
Jake:有人已经有人买了
Jake: Someone already bought it.
其他人：那不是呵呵呵
Others: Isn’t that funny?
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha
其他人：我说我现在账户里已经有150个ego币了
Others: I’m saying I already have 150 ego coins in my account.
Jake:哦牛批
Jake: Oh, that's awesome.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Cool, cool.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
Shure: 然后我们怎么分发呢
Shure: So, how do we distribute them?
Shure: 这个最后会有有
Shure: In the end, we’ll...
Shure: 有这个matemask卖色的就分
Shure: Distribute among those who have Metamask, right?
Shure: 没有的就不分是吧
Shure: Those who don't, won't get any, right?
其他人：我的想法是
Others: My idea is...
其他人：最后
Others: In the end...
其他人：今天大家每个人最后手里有多少个ego币
Others: By the end of today, everyone will have a certain amount of ego coins.
Shure: 那怎么发呢
Shure: So how do we distribute them?
Shure: 万一有人没有这个钱包呢
Shure: What if someone doesn't have the wallet?
其他人：发钱包也不
Others: Distributing wallets too is not...
其他人：要钱
Others: Costly.
其他人：但我不知道这个
Others: But I don’t know if...
其他人：发钱包会不会要燃油费啊
Others: Distributing wallets will incur gas fees?
其他人：也他妈发一个
Others: Damn it, distribute one...
其他人：ego币不要钱
Others: Ego coin doesn’t cost anything.
其他人：燃油费他妈
Others: But gas fees, damn it...
其他人：那没事我还有
Others: Doesn’t matter, I still have more.
Shure: 知道这是干嘛的吗
Shure: Do you know what this is for?
其他人：测温的
Others: For measuring temperature.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
其他人： 那你加一个面包我要先吃一下
Others: Add a bread, I want to eat first.
Shure: 我有
Shure: I have it.
Shure: 怎么搞
Shure: How do we do this?
Shure: 草那账单账户密码记不记得
Shure: Damn it, do you remember the account password?
Shure: 我同意导入现有钱包
Shure: I agree to import the existing wallet.
Shure: 我同意
Shure: I agree.
其他人：嗯你用什么软件Matmax
Others: Hmm, what software are you using, Matmax?
Shure: Matmax
Shure: Matmax.
其他人：还在录着呢
Others: Still recording
其他人：卧槽
Others: Damn
其他人：我要把你助记词全全他妈记下来
Others: I'm going to remember all your mnemonic phrases
Shure: 哼好
Shure: Hmm, okay
Shure: 我给发过
Shure: I sent it before
Shure: 我的助记词
Shure: My mnemonic phrases
Shure: （歌词）哒哒哒爱人的歌
Shure: (lyrics) Da da da lover's song
Shure: 别他妈他妈创个币
Shure: Don't damn create a coin
Shure: 还有手续费我真绷不住了
Shure: And the transaction fees, I really can't handle it
其他人：但这个币本身已经很贵了
Others: But this coin itself is already expensive
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
其他人：我花了400块钱
Others: I spent 400 yuan
Shure: 那他现在是跟跟那个以太坊
Shure: So now it has a real-time exchange rate with Ethereum?
Shure: 相当于有实时汇率吗还是
Shure: Or what?
其他人：基本实时它现在不值钱0美刀
Others: Basically real-time, but now it's worthless, zero dollars
其他人：感觉从这个
Others: Feels like from this
其他人：我们的成本上这币每个都已经3块钱
Others: Our cost makes each coin already 3 yuan
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: OK了来吧
Shure: Okay, let's go
其他人：来吧
Others: Let's go
Shure: 收款
Shure: Payment
其他人：给你搞搞5个币怎么样
Others: How about I get you 5 coins?
Shure: 对先给我搞5个
Shure: Yes, get me 5 first
其他人：你手里有5个吧
Others: Do you have 5?
Shure: 我一分没有
Shure: I don't have a cent
其他人：那你得发给我押金
Others: Then you need to send me a deposit
其他人：押我100块
Others: Deposit 100 yuan
其他人：你如果今天活动结束有5个
Others: If you have 5 by the end of the event today
Shure: 好好好你快快转吧
Shure: Okay, okay, hurry up and transfer
Shure: 先别墨迹了
Shure: Stop wasting time
Lucia: 这比巧克力宣传整颗榛子还离谱
Lucia: This is more ridiculous than chocolate advertising whole hazelnuts
Lucia: 因为它真的是整颗雪梨
Lucia: Because it's really a whole pear
Lucia: 你看我一捞上来我就惊呆了
Lucia: Look, I was stunned when I scooped it up
Jake:吃应该比较好分吧
Jake: It should be easier to divide up to eat, right?
Jake:要自己分就很离谱
Jake: It's ridiculous to divide it yourself
Shure: 燃油费要多少
Shure: How much is the gas fee?
其他人：绷不住了哈哈
Others: Can't handle it, haha
Shure: 那我们只能最后一洗
Shure: Then we can only wash it one last time
其他人：共十几只
Others: A total of a few
其他人：好吧我们就够我们信任几只
Others: Okay, we just need to trust a few
Shure: 我给你们寄账单
Shure: I'll send you guys the bill.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：这他妈得多少钱啊
Others: How much is this gonna cost?
Shure: 0.00000
Shure: 0.00000.
其他人：他这个是他这个是市场决定的
Others: This is market-driven.
其他人：你知道吗
Others: You know?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 0.0005对吧
Shure: 0.0005, right?
其他人：嗯这也不便宜
Others: Yeah, that's not cheap either.
Jake:你要不找一个固定的叉子
Jake: Why not find a fixed fork?
Jake:你要是你活动
Jake: If you're active...
Shure: 不4块钱吗
Shure: Isn't it 4 bucks?
其他人：0块啊两块一毛6
Others: No, it's 0 bucks, 2 bucks and 1.6 dimes.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：牛逼啊
Others: Awesome!
Shure: 那最后的时候再弄呗
Shure: We'll do it at the end then.
Shure: 就是计完之后
Shure: After calculating.
Shure: 等燃油费便宜的时候再弄
Shure: When the fuel fee gets cheaper.
Shure: 不还有那个d选项什么的那个
Shure: There's also that option D, right?
其他人：这就是要等啊
Others: We just have to wait.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：懂吧他这也是市场浮动的
Others: You see, it's also market-driven.
Shure: 懂了
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Jake:哎怎么没有充电宝
Jake: Hey, why are there no power banks?
Shure: 没有充电宝
Shure: No power banks.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: （歌词）darling just catch me slow
Shure: (lyrics) Darling just catch me slow.
Jake:来整俩充电宝
Jake: Let's get two power banks.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 这
Shure: Here.
Shure: ok
Shure: Ok.
其他人：只要我靠谱
Others: As long as I stay reliable.
其他人：这个币就有价值
Others: This currency will have value.
Jake:你怎么靠谱
Jake: How can you be reliable?
其他人：因为我现在就必须得
Others: Because I just have to...
其他人：记住每个人多少钱
Others: Keep track of everyone's money.
其他人：我没办法直接给他们
Others: I can't just give it to them directly.
其他人：啊直接给他们他妈太坑
Others: Yeah, giving it to them directly would be too shady.
Jake:那那怎么办
Jake: Then what to do?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Shure: 都给你录下来了
Shure: I've recorded everything for you
其他人：这不挺好听的吗
Other: Doesn't it sound pretty good?
Lucia: 看起来好像可以用的样子
Lucia: It looks like it can be used
Lucia: 我可以现在把它摘下来安一下吗
Lucia: Can I take it down and install it now?
Tasha: 谁给我拿了
Tasha: Who took it for me?
Lucia: 本来民宿的
Lucia: Originally for the guesthouse
Lucia: supposed to拿我们所有人的快递
Lucia: Supposed to pick up all our packages
Lucia: 你昨天应该说一声
Lucia: You should've said something yesterday
Lucia: 我要知道你没拿我们就跟你一块去
Lucia: If I knew you didn't pick it up, I would've gone with you
Tasha: 我给他打电话了
Tasha: I called him
Lucia: 领导这是你的你的问题了
Lucia: Boss, this is your problem
Lucia: 领导你反思哈哈
Lucia: Boss, reflect on it, haha
Lucia: 我觉得民宿
Lucia: I think the guesthouse
Lucia: 他们这个工作态度要提升一下呀
Lucia: Their work attitude needs some improvement
Lucia: 我们真的要去三亚吗
Lucia: Are we really going to Sanya?
Lucia: 我还没有去过
Lucia: I haven't been there
Lucia: 没去过
Lucia: Never been
Lucia: 所以您要是在三亚做实验的话
Lucia: So if you're doing experiments in Sanya
Lucia: 你看我这个工作态度和效率怎么样
Lucia: Check out my work attitude and efficiency
Shure: 什么什么时候去三亚呀老板
Shure: Boss, when are we going to Sanya?
Jake:什么时候去
Jake: When are we going?
Jake:五一之后去走
Jake: After May 1st, we'll go
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 你等我答完辩的
Shure: Wait for me to finish my defense
Shure: 好吧我正好正好公费度蜜月去了
Shure: Okay, I'll just go on a free honeymoon
Tasha: 不等
Tasha: No waiting
Shure: 怎么样
Shure: How about it?
Tasha: 公费度蜜月你还要把你女朋友带上
Tasha: Free honeymoon, you still have to bring your girlfriend
Shure: 我们干活效率都很高
Shure: We all work very efficiently
Tasha: 哦是你啊
Tasha: Oh, it's you
Tasha: 想看看是哪位男生
Tasha: Wanted to see which guy
Alice:啊累死我了
Alice: Ah, I'm exhausted
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Tasha: 你女朋友在北京吗
Tasha: Is your girlfriend in Beijing?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Tasha: 哦是他的
Tasha: Oh, it's his
Tasha: 在西安
Tasha: In Xi'an
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: Huh, what?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 我说是他的在西安
Tasha: I said his girlfriend is in Xi'an.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 谁女朋友在西安
Lucia: Whose girlfriend is in Xi'an?
Tasha: 他女朋友啊
Tasha: His girlfriend.
Lucia: 想认识一下美女小姐姐
Lucia: I want to meet this pretty lady.
Tasha: 呵呵怎么回事
Tasha: Haha, what's going on?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 因为我在西安
Lucia: Because I'm in Xi'an.
Tasha: 我知道我说他怎么不说话哎
Tasha: I know, I was wondering why he wasn't talking.
Shure: 那你会说陕西话吗
Shure: Can you speak Shaanxi dialect?
Lucia: 我会
Lucia: I can.
Lucia: 但我说的可能不那么标准
Lucia: But maybe not very fluently.
Lucia: 不过北方话反正本来就是变个调
Lucia: Anyway, northern dialects are all about changing tones.
其他人：现在我说陕西话感觉也挺好听
Others: Now that I speak Shaanxi dialect, it sounds pretty nice.
Lucia: 怎么了要我说一段吗哈
Lucia: What's up, want me to say something in it?
Shure: 老辣子溜馍
Shure: Old spicy bread.
Shure: 哈哈绿绿辣子
Shure: Haha, green spicy bread.
Lucia: 哈哈你这舌撒的咋听不懂啊哈哈
Lucia: Haha, I can't understand your accent, haha.
Shure: 绿辣子溜馍
Shure: Green spicy bread.
Shure: 什么那个
Shure: What the...
Lucia: 不知道不过我我
Lucia: I don't know, but I...
Lucia: 因为我们家一般不说山西话
Lucia: Because my family generally doesn't speak Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 就是只有只有我姥姥姥爷那一辈的
Lucia: Only my grandparents' generation does.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 他们才说山西话
Lucia: They speak Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 对其实我在家其实也说普通话
Lucia: Actually, we speak Mandarin at home.
Lucia: 就是说的就说的
Lucia: It's just...
Lucia: 不是很标准
Lucia: Not very fluently.
Lucia: 但是我同学都说
Lucia: But my classmates say...
Lucia: 说的还可以
Lucia: It's pretty good.
Lucia: 但是可能是同学给我给面子你知道吧
Lucia: But maybe my classmates are just being polite, you know?
Shure: 完了武林外传的味上来了
Shure: Now it sounds like "My Own Swordsman".
Shure: 佟掌柜哈哈哈
Shure: Tong shopkeeper, haha.
Shure: 你今天要不就一直这样
Shure: Why don't you keep talking like this today?
Shure: 我进来要来了呢
Shure: I'm coming in.
Shure: 你啊你
Shure: You, you...
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Shure: 比如说那个那个有有客人来了
Shure: For example, if a guest arrives...
Shure: 你会怎么说
Shure: How would you say it?
Shure: 用用那个山西话啊
Shure: In Shanxi dialect?
Shure: 不是陕西话
Shure: Not Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 吃馍还是吃还是吃啥
Lucia: Eating steamed buns or what else?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 俺也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:他说下午统一取
Alice: He said we should pick it up in the afternoon.
Alice:下午不就晚了
Alice: Isn't the afternoon too late?
Jake:对所以我们直接自己走
Jake: Yeah, so we should just go by ourselves.
Alice:我有两个我的都到了
Alice: I have two, both of mine arrived.
Lucia: 他那里面是整颗雪梨
Lucia: There's a whole snow pear inside.
Lucia: 不过已经被我吃掉了一部分
Lucia: But I already ate part of it.
Alice:所以什么时候拿快递啊
Alice: So when are we picking up the package?
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now.
Jake:哎谢斌竹帮忙
Jake: Hey, Xie Bin Zhu, help me out.
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This one, this one.
Shure: 俺是河南的
Shure: I'm from Henan.
Shure: 河南许昌的
Shure: From Xuchang, Henan.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 只有两个了谢谢
Lucia: Only two left, thanks.
Shure: 怎么办
Shure: What to do?
Shure: 什么东西啊
Shure: What's that?
Alice:他们已经去取快递了吗
Alice: Have they gone to pick up the package?
Shure: 还没
Shure: Not yet.
Lucia: 我发到你的聊天框里吧
Lucia: I'll send it to your chat box.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哇哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Wahahaha
Lucia: 也可以或
Lucia: That works too.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 面阳光风啊
Shure: Face the sunshine and the wind.
Shure: what are you doing bro
Shure: What are you doing, bro?
Lucia: 我在找一个剪刀
Lucia: I'm looking for scissors.
Lucia: 你昨天有在这里看
Lucia: You looked here yesterday.
Lucia: 或者今天早上
Lucia: Or this morning.
Lucia: 在这看到一个透明色的剪刀吗
Lucia: Did you see a pair of transparent scissors here?
Shure: no
Shure: No.
Lucia: 嗯奇怪
Lucia: Hmm, weird.
Shure: nope
Shure: Nope.
Lucia: 到处都没有哎
Lucia: They're nowhere to be found.
Lucia: 离大谱了没有
Lucia: Is this completely off track or what?
Lucia: 好奇怪我昨天晚上在那里用的
Lucia: It's so weird, I was using it there last night.
Lucia: 然后就还放在那了
Lucia: And then I just left it there.
Shure: 你好美女
Shure: Hello, beautiful.
Shure: 嘛呢您
Shure: What are you up to?
Shure: 呵压花
Shure: Oh, pressing flowers.
Katrina: 哎怎么塞不进去啊
Katrina: Hey, why can't I fit it in?
Shure: 是那首v是吗
Shure: Is that the V song?
Katrina: 不知道推的什么歌
Katrina: I don't know what song is being played.
Shure: 这是我某一年的年度单曲
Shure: This was my song of the year one year.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 当我飞奔向你
Katrina: When I ran towards you.
Katrina: 不是那个青春剧吗
Katrina: Isn't that from a youth drama?
Shure: 我没看过那个剧
Shure: I haven't watched that drama.
Shure: 但是我知道这个star moon
Shure: But I know this song, "Star Moon."
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Shure: 我的那个特别特别大的那个花呢
Shure: Where's that really big flower of mine?
Shure: 在哪在哪
Shure: Where is it, where is it?
Shure: 是这朵吗嗯
Shure: Is it this one, hmm?
Katrina: 嗯只能把它单独着
Katrina: Yeah, you can only keep it separate.
Shure: 他怎么感觉没没抽干呢这个气
Shure: Why does it feel like the air isn't fully sucked out?
Katrina: 大的确实有点
Katrina: The big one really isn't.
Katrina: 完全没干
Katrina: It’s not dried at all.
Shure: 那怎么怎么抽呢
Shure: Then how do you suck it out?
Shure: 一般是拿嘴吸吗
Shure: Do you usually use your mouth to suck it?
Katrina: 什么呀你说你说这个吗
Katrina: What? You mean this?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 我就用手的
Katrina: I just use my hand.
Katrina: 这他他其实就是一层那个掀起来的
Katrina: Actually, it's just a layer that lifts up.
Katrina: 盖上就感觉就很难了
Katrina: Covering it feels quite difficult.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 我以为你这个口就是留着吸的
Shure: I thought you left this opening to suck out the air.
Shure: 然后里面这些小气泡是你的唾液
Shure: And these little bubbles inside are your saliva.
Katrina: 哇这么恶心
Katrina: Wow, that's so gross.
Katrina: 这个真太劣质了
Katrina: This thing is really poorly made.
Shure: (歌词)baby that i'm fool for you baby
Shure: (Lyrics) baby that I'm a fool for you baby
Shure: (歌词)i'm a fool for you
Shure: (Lyrics) I'm a fool for you
Katrina: 塞进去
Katrina: Fit it in.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Katrina: 把你的吉他拿出来练练
Katrina: Take out your guitar and practice a bit.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哇真的好爽啊
Shure: Wow, this feels so good.
Shure: 外面这个阳光今天
Shure: The sunshine outside today...
Shure: 那才5:20
Shure: It's only 5:20.
Lucia: 这个我昨天也用了
Lucia: I used this yesterday too.
Lucia: 但是他没有捡到
Lucia: But he didn't pick it up.
Lucia: 灵活就我昨天切瓶子的时候用了
Lucia: So flexible, I used it when I cut the bottle yesterday.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Lucia: 我靠好奇怪啊
Lucia: Oh my, that's so strange.
Lucia: 他怎么能就没有了呢
Lucia: How could it just disappear?
Shure: 小夹子呢
Shure: Where's the clip?
Shure: 哎呀妈呀
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 要钱
Shure: Need money.
Shure: 不付
Shure: Not paying.
Shure: 我们要复习
Shure: We need to review.
Shure: 复习什么呢
Shure: What should we review?
Shure: 哦晴天是吧
Shure: Oh, "Sunny Day," right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey